[Applause]
but tonight we're kicking it off with
two of the biggest names with the
smallest bodies and the biggest dicks in
comedy
david spade and kevin hart
and the last thing i need is to lose
another job to kevin hart
okay i don't need that
kev kev right there can make movies fast
every month porno stars don't make
movies that fast
he's a dangerous dude he's my friend
yeah he's not playing
team wrestling match shut up stupid shut
up
you're right hush okay oh boy wait a
minute i'll shut them up
all right all right fine you know how
many beautiful people will be here
right out here central time my man kevin
i'm going to do my part
yeah i know i'm going to do my part
we're seeing our cards right now
don't give me a second well [ __ ] your
car because my car where's my car oh
yes
oh this is [ __ ] look at this
[ __ ] my ass you ain't gonna get a
car
you need to get a car how am i how are
we here
in london this is my town and there is
no
you see it aha oh hold on a second
hold on a second kevin hart look
yes the big one goes by
for the big man himself yes
the king of the world [ __ ] your little
car
how do you get the bus big bus no that
was a big budget
a little car yeah go go get a little car
get yourself phone book sit on
and the other legendary thing about
little kev is he has a dick the side
of a baby arm it's really depressing oh
you've seen it no but i've heard it
suppresses me
and i don't even need to say the no homo
thing it's just like you know
if if you know girls are like you know
hey hi
how are you the [ __ ] might be
like hey and it's like
hey and he just goes look i got a big
dick
excellent tv we got excellence in movies
too
a lot of excellent black movies man and
some of them don't even have kevin
hartner
there are movies kevin hart's in
everything
my man is in every
movie there is i think i see kevin and
sometimes he in the trailer and not in
the movie
so i saw him in magnificent kevin hart
angelina joe leaves he was playing a
bush i was like
is that cat get out of here kevin and
transformers
it turned into a prius of another cam
look at kev
how about you kev ah you know what if i
wanted anyone to be president i wanted
to be shaq
because shaq can do whatever the hell he
wants shaq can call you in right now
and tell him that he wants to bomb
france they're going to say but why shaq
they didn't do anything uh i don't know
i don't like the basketball team
i think the basketball team stinks i
want to drop a bomb on him i want to
dunk it
he called me with that shack and you
think this shack is gonna be good yeah
today's guest is a true friend a real
brother
they've developed me since 2003. you you
shut up bill people don't know that this
is bill byrne
ladies and gentlemen hey hey i'm bill
bird now evan hart was somebody that i
thought i was friends with but i
realized quickly that he just needed to
spawn at danger
fields and then he booked a pilot and i
don't think i talked to him again
i had like kids and i didn't hear from
you bill
burns ladies and gentlemen we're getting
into the mind of bill bill
late for his own podcast bill are you
ready for this this is the best part
that i think
this is this is what's mind-blowing that
people are going to love
bill brother grab your your own name on
your [ __ ] sweatshirt
well outside of that i mean brandon we
know who you are
just in case you didn't bill i wore a
shirt to remind you what's the big
[ __ ] deal man
all right it's just a hoodie with kevin
hart i hand out hoodies to homeless
people because i care about downtown l.a
go see jumanji part 19.
the studio system has ruined you
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
i got to say [ __ ] about playing sports
in school did they show football
you didn't play i got varsity nine
through twelve what what was your
what was your locking number quick
locking numbers what was the jersey
number
one what was the name number five yeah
yeah and what did you do
we play football that's how you that's
how we do sports basketball
40 and 140 how much did you play
and starting at fetus